قررت نقابه المهن التمثيليه في مصر حاله
العاملين في فيلم سنه اولى خطف الى
التحقيق بسبب تجاوز الوقت المسموح فيه
بالتصوير خلال احد الايام النقابه انا
قرارها عبر فيسبوك نستنكره استمرار عمليه
تصوير 24 ساعه متتاليه يتخيل وهو ما يعد
مخالفه للوائح التي اقرتها فيما يخص عمل
الممثلين كما منعت التعامل مع الشركه
المنتجه هي ازمه متكرره في صناعه السينما
والدراما في مصر وتشتد عاده في رمضان
للحاق بالموسم بعد الاعمال يجري تصويرها
حتى قبل ايام من عيد الفطر
ومنذ عامين توفي احد المصورين بشكل مفاجئ
وارجع البعض ان وفاته كانت بسبب الارهاق
والعمل بشكل متواصل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات